the moon had been something that
photographers had tried to photograph
um right from the beginning when the
gare even tried
um and it didn't work partly because the
plates are pretty
insensitive to light the moon is quite
faint really
and then of course the earth rotates
which means if you have a long exposure
you're going to get a blur and you can
actually see that in the gear type in
the middle
but in 1851 the guy who was the son of
the director of the harvard college
observatory
in a boston portrait daguerreotype is
because most aguero types were
portraits paired up and they figured out
how to
to do it um and they had to rotate the
telescope
you know ever so slightly yeah so that
it would follow the rotation of the
earth
um on these pictures and they made them
just you know
there were as incredible then as they
are today
in the end photography didn't do more
than drawing a good drawing could but
because they were photographs they had
it was real yeah it was real and this
album like nate smith and carpenter
i mean this was hailed as the triumph of
astronomical photography
by astronomers um but what's amazing is
that the photographs are plaster models
and the astronomers know that i mean
there are plaster models based on
drawings made through the telescope and
astronomers were perfectly aware of what
they were looking at
but they felt that because they were
photographed that they added this sort
of layer of authenticity
to the undertaking that simple drawings
didn't have
down two and a half
forward forward
at 40 feet down two and a half
picking up some dust thirty feet two and
a half down
straight shadow four forward
four forward drifting to the right level
and a half 30 seconds
contact light
okay engine stop aca had a defense
oh control both auto defend engine
command override off
and then i'm off or 13 is in
tranquility we copy on the ground you
got a bunch of guys about to turn blue
we're breathing again
thanks a lot
you